well hello hello can i have a lateral
flow test please yes
yes every year there's a must-have item
people are scrambling for on christmas
eve this year amid rising infection
rates it's covered tests there you go
there's seven tests in one box all right
that's okay bye merry christmas
come to a pharmacy like this and the
shortage of lateral flow tests is
apparent they've only had one box
delivered this week which means these
are likely to be gone within a matter of
hours
hopes that we can all test before
different households mix aren't the
reality
with the whole nhs system at the moment
it's it's been a bit of a nightmare but
one of the problems we're having at the
moment and having to deal with is
patients coming in and trying to get
hold of lateral flows so that they can
meet with family during christmas but
we've just not been able to get hold of
any
and of course this year there's another
course to our christmas dinner a booster
jab the prime minister saying the best
last minute present any of us could give
our family members is a vaccine means
volunteers up and down the country have
had to step up we've got about six
vaccinators ready for this and we also
have
the full team of marshals admins they're
all ready for for this there's a lot of
people coming at the age of 50 and 60
coming for the first jab so that is that
that clearly shows the uptick is
increasing amid the sea of last minute
internet orders making their way through
the post pity those trapped inside still
waiting for delayed pcr test results now
practically too late to go and see
family well we'll be here for christmas
uh my husband will be doing a mad dash
out to get some food because we
currently don't have any because we
didn't bother um
my kids are gonna be well my youngest
not so much he's only two but my five
year old is going to be devastated he's
not with his cousins and his nana and
granddad than that so yeah
it would still happen it'd just be a
delayed happen
christmas hasn't been cancelled this
year but with it constantly under threat
a reminder there are still presents you
can't buy online
katie spencer sky news